well so there you go now you've been in
government you know that there are ways
to make things happen we work to
persuade people
and here she is thinking especially with
president biden it would have an impact
what's your take on that
well what she's talking about is
shutting down american pipelines that
bring energy to households
they keep households warm in the winter
they keep households cool
in the summer that protect the elderly
and the young
i mean this is about physical safety for
millions of americans
it's about affordability for blue-collar
families
this is really an attack on working
people but i want to make another point
you have to ask
the question you're talking about who's
hurting our country what kind of
movement
holds up as a leader even venerates a
person like jane fonda what she did in
the vietnam war
people may have forgotten this was she
volunteered herself
as a tool of north vietnamese communist
propaganda
she did propaganda broadcast on their
radio station
in north vietnam she sat on their
anti-aircraft battery
that's used to shoot down american
planes
and american airmen i mean this is by
any definition and i'm going to use the
word by any definition which she did in
the vietnam war
is treason and she is held up as a hero
and look aid and comforting of the enemy
uh it was
clear in that regard and this is when we
think about it
well it's just jane fonda or it's just a
one-off situation
it's not this is a mentality that feeds
uh
the movement even to this day when we
talk about america last we're not
kidding are we
no i mean it's a mindset just like
reflexively
jane fonda rushed to the defense of the
communists in vietnam
who were killing our boys overseas
now she is rushing to help people
like vladimir putin and like china and
like other countries
by shutting down u.s energy who does it
help when you shut down our energy
production
it helps our foreign adversaries around
the globe and you know we hear this
from so many leftists and first of all i
want you to also hear joy reid
now she says a lot of surprising things
but here are her comments backing up the
vice president on the border let's
listen to this
this is a perhaps unpopular opinion
uh in the business right now but i think
we need to
have some perspective the united states
southern border with mexico
is not the only important
issue that matters to the world
those seven countries have a long
history with the united states
much of it troubling the united states
used much
of central america as essentially a
giant plantation
well and here you've got women's lives
being ruined children's lives being
ruined
sex trafficking drugs coming over the
border but it's not such a global issue
she says uh what's your reaction first
of all
is there a more important issue for any
country
then whether or not it has defends and
maintains a border
what nation and what civilization has
long endured
that failed to protect and defend its
own borders it's fundamental
to survival as a country as a
civilization
secondly what do we think the odds are
that she has doors on her home and locks
on those doors i mean what are the what
are the odds
that she has a car that she locks when
she leaves it at night
i mean this is our country we're talking
about and then what about
all the people as you mentioned that are
raped and brutalized on the journey
north
she wants to blame american colonialism
you know what caused poverty
you know what caused mayhem throughout
the western hemisphere
and in particular in latin america
leftist governments and socialist
policies and marxist policies exactly
that destroyed the economies of latin
america and then they want to export
those policies here this is what these
people are are escaping
this is why we are the shining city on
the hill we are the last hope for people
escaping
what those nations did through socialism
continue to try to do
uh well thank you so much steven great
stuff and america first legal of course
doing great work thanks for joining me
tonight i appreciate your perspective
thank you so much thank you sir
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else